hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday July 23rd 2018 how's it going
how are you what do you say there before
I get going I have something to promote
old freckles all ringside red face is
going to be at the next rough and rowdy
event August 1st in Youngstown Ohio
legendary legendary in the fight game
Youngstown Ohio
it's Sunday August 5th 2018 at 7:00 p.m.
Eastern Time
you can pre-order at our n r4
pay-per-view stream you go right to the
website rough and rowdy brawl calm our
Oh ugh the letter n ro wdy brawl BR awl
calm check it out I was at the last one
and you know it's one of the most
favorite things I've ever done in show
business it's just you know it's
everything you want to see you know it's
it's it's conflicting groups of people
duking it out with not a lot of skill
you just get to sit there and enjoy it
I'm thinking there's gonna be a lot of
maniacs there as you know Youngstown is
no joke all right
and I can't wait to be there and not
fight anybody like the coward that I am
uh having said that let me be uh let me
live my best life let me be a hero to
myself Michaels through the second half
of 2018 is to be my own personal hero
these [ __ ] social media people have
you ever like there's nothing I didn't
know where to begin with this if I see
one more [ __ ] fat miserable loser
with wearing a t-shirt
that has some sort of self-help advice
to me like they've reached the mecca of
peace and happiness it's just like who
is that [ __ ] t-shirt for yours is it
for me you know I just saw this this
[ __ ] miserable looking person sitting
down in the airport you know tens and
tens and tens of [ __ ] pounds
overweight eating [ __ ] food with a
t-shirt that says love yourself you know
what I mean and all of this [ __ ] crap
now will you Pat people on the back
because they're [ __ ] up their lives
but they still feel good about you know
what I like Who I am I'm not saying you
shouldn't like who you are but I mean
you got to look at yourself in the
mirror at some point and just be like do
the [ __ ] are we doing here you know not
saying I'm perfect I'm not right but I'm
not you know sitting around here like
calling myself a hero you know based off
of all my [ __ ] shortcomings Hollywood
puts pressure in effect a night it's not
a Hollywood Hollywood gives people what
they want alright you [ __ ] [ __ ] so
sick of everybody blaming this innocent
town we here in Hollywood happen to be
some of the the most dependable loyal
honest human beings you ever gonna meet
yeah I couldn't even get through without
laughing
whatever [ __ ] you this cut this time
will give you whatever the [ __ ] you buy
okay and you've been looking at [ __ ]
abs and big tits since the second they
had moving pictures so I don't want to
[ __ ] hear these [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know then I like those other people the
the [ __ ] fat guys with the with the
tough-guy [ __ ] on their shirt you know
do I look like I give a [ __ ] you know
that's no no you don't yeah I don't I
would believe
you don't give a [ __ ] about anything all
right with you [ __ ] fungus riddled
toenails while wearing your little
[ __ ] flip-flops oh my god you ever
see people that they had toenails they
look like [ __ ] petrified wood and
they're literally walking around just
you know I guess living their best life
but making you look at him I swear to
god man I saw somebody an airport
recently that had these flip-flops that
also had like this toenail flap on it
Joe's really excited but I hear stomping
feet that can only mean one thing
aah hey buddy how you doing daddy's in
here making a fool of himself look how
big you're getting oh oh come on buddy
do what your mom says trust me I've
tried it the other way it doesn't work
all right
the money money podcast has been briefly
interrupted Oh somebody's tired bye-bye
oh you want to say hi let me give her a
hug hang on I get a positive
all right I'm back crisis averted
the [ __ ] was I talking about how great
people are in Hollywood how trustworthy
we are you know there's a couple of bad
apples so I'm not gonna lie to you
there's a few people out here you know I
might be one of those people who knows
you know anyways what was I talking
about
doggone it Jesus Christ I just
interrupted Christ it got my hope I
don't know what I was talking who gives
a [ __ ] right what do I hit stop and go
back and [ __ ] try and listen to it
anyways I have no idea what I was
talking about
let me plow ahead here as I always do
I swear to god this [ __ ] house I
swear to god this [ __ ] house if it's
not one thing it's another
every time I get something fixed
something else breaks you don't I mean
this can't be what owning a house is
like I just I had to have bought out
there's got to be some sort of [ __ ]
lemon law it's I'm [ __ ] it's
un-fuckin'-believable what are those
people they have a lawyer on retainer
that just means that constantly getting
in [ __ ] trouble so they're just
constantly paying the [ __ ] guy I
should have a plumber on retainer I know
what that means what the [ __ ] does that
mean
it just sounds cool I have a lawyer on
retainer oh my god oh my god give me an
idea what my dad does that is god I
still cannot get over the fact that an
adult said that to another adult do you
have any idea what the [ __ ] my dad does
you know it's like it's like you're
there and the other guys there you guys
are facing off with each other and then
the [ __ ] another dude grabs her by
the throat throws him down to the ground
and then he stands up and all he has is
you're [ __ ] you're [ __ ] and I
evidently he walks away to go get his
dad the kids in his 20s
what's the matter is that 35 year old
across the street picking on you again
son anyways I went down to Comic Con old
freckles who's done nothing but make fun
of comic-con forever I went down there
on Thursday because Vince and all the
guys that better call Saul were nice
enough to ask me to mediate is that the
word basically hosts the panel the
better call Saul to promote this season
premiere August 6th on AMC season 4
premiere and and after that the 10 year
Breaking Bad reunion ten years since
their first
de beauté I would think 2008 and I went
down there and it was all these people
dressed like superheroes most people are
not dressed up but there's enough people
that dressed up that it was cool and I
went down there and I got to tell you I
really liked those [ __ ] nerds man
they were really cool people I only
teased them one time because I was
saying something that was a spoiler and
I was like hey spoiler alerts everybody
saw it last season better call Saul you
saw what happened in last episode and
this dude down front was like yeah I
didn't see it and I was like I will
stick a couple of lights safer than you
here cuz I have to [ __ ] read this
show something like then everybody
laughed everybody had a good time with
it I wasn't sure you know the self
sabotage Jimmy wanted to walk out and
open with how you doing you [ __ ]
nerds but I just didn't want to bring
him back to high school I figured I was
in their dojo I'm gonna be polite you
know I mean as fun as it is to do what
that [ __ ] guy in Fox News did that
one time when he went on that show with
Barbara Walters you know remember that
and half the [ __ ] crew of him walked
off the stage
I can't remember anybody's [ __ ] names
anymore anyways I was down there and I
had a great time and I flew with my
instructor down there and an r44 it's
the first time I've flown I hadn't flown
since the end of May you know I was
overseas you know doing gigs and
celebrating my birthday probably far too
long admittedly and then the last week
of June I you know in the beginning of
July had to get caught up with all the
work that I lost I missed I mean sorry
and I flew and I did all right man you
know little rusty at first and it all
[ __ ] came back and I had my best F
and landing I've ever had as far as you
know not having to look at my
instruments too much and just feeling
just feeling it being coming one with
the [ __ ] machine there was getting
dark out we came back to Burbank and we
were listening to the ADIS which is just
the information that's updated every
hour for the airport you have to listen
to it it's some computer voice you know
we're discovering
girl you have information Nike so then
you get on with Burbank tower you like
Burbank Tower helicopter blah blah blah
blah blah blah bluh atelic on Hollywood
reservoir requesting full stop at
Atlantic with information Yankee so they
know you got the latest information then
they tell you what to do now there was a
bunch of traffic coming in so they told
us to hold over old Mako which is this
[ __ ] hunk of [ __ ] Macy's off the 170s
that they're finally redoing and you
just [ __ ] orbit over there to all the
big boys go in and then they say you
know helicopter blah blah blah cleared
for landing runway 8 west of Delta 8 so
that you just say all that [ __ ] back so
I said all that [ __ ] back I come in they
got the the [ __ ] whatever they like
oh you know those [ __ ] the power
lines there she'd that chop your head
off I flew over the tower like you're
supposed to not over the wires and then
I was coming in at the right speed
because it was a jet behind me but I was
a little too high so I just banked it
really hard using my G's to make the
[ __ ] helicopter heavier don't ask me
how physics right and then it [ __ ]
came down I was going coming down like
600 feet per minute which as long as I'm
moving forward is fine but as I slowed
down I got it down to 300 commercial
[ __ ] landing right in the [ __ ]
glide path right on the numbers and
[ __ ] bang the left on Delta 8 and my
instructor goes that's the best landing
you've ever done you're becoming one
with the helicopter and I turned around
and my wife's in the back and her
headphones weren't working and she
didn't hear it and you know what I hate
to say it so it was like it never
happened
and I was literally sitting there like a
five-year-old talking to my mom going
there did you hear that did you and she
was like wow you know there's a part of
me that actually thinks she did here you
know but to keep me and [ __ ] lying to
keep me keep chasing the [ __ ] carrot
she acted like she didn't hear it so
anyways moving along I want to thank
everybody on the cast of Breaking Bad
and better call Saul for doing the heavy
lifting and telling the stories and all
that I mean I was having like
you know nightmares about hosting that
and me turning into the real version of
Chris Farley you know that that
character he would do they Paul
McCartney remember we you you and John
Lennon you guys wrote the White Album
yes Chris yes I do here that was awesome
like I was worried that I was gonna be
doing that I'm not gonna say there
wasn't a couple moments of that but uh
you know the whole time I was up there I
was like why didn't they get Jimmy
Kimmel to do this that's my first
[ __ ] thought because I remember he
did he did the when they had the final
episode and in LA they did this thing at
the Hollywood Forever Cemetery and they
showed the the final episode you can set
outside and [ __ ] with all these other
Breaking Bad fans it was really a
[ __ ] awesome night and Kimmel hosted
and he did a great job so I imagined the
reason why he didn't do it was because
he had to host his own show and yeah
that makes sense right he had the host
his talk show tapes at 5:00 and that was
gonna be from 3 till 5:30 down in San
Diego oh there we go there you go that's
why old freckles got called up from the
- for a cup of coffee
speaking of cut and called up from the
minors and a cup of coffee and all that
I'm back into watching the red sox
Braley's paying attention man I'd
started with me trying like using
listening to baseball as a way to not
flip out in traffic and you know and
just settling in to just not I just
stopped fighting the city just like yeah
man there's gonna be a lot of traffic
there's gonna be a lot of people doing
things that I'm not gonna like and I
just need to just I'm just gonna sit
there and watch it happen
and just sort of inch along as I listen
to five innings of a baseball game and
go maybe three-quarters of a mile that's
what I'm gonna do and that's what I've
been doing and I just listen to the Red
Sox games and the Red Sox I'll tell you
dude they're on yeah I was worried that
the all-star break was going to slow him
down
Dave won 10 out of 11 I'm sorry they
want 11 out of 10 Ella they want 11 out
of 12 that's right because they want 10
and oh then they lost 1 and then they
won right for the all-star game
I know I sound like the [ __ ] Rain Man
then we just took two out of three from
the Tigers so we won 13 out of the last
15 and the Yankees just keep winning too
but I got to tell you I watched a little
bit of the Astros to have been watching
those guys I still think they're the
team to beat they get Verlander they got
a great pitching staff and they got the
bats they got the whole [ __ ] thing
and they won it last year and nobody's
really talking about him everybody's all
excited for [ __ ] Yankees Red Sox and
this is what I think all right Yankees
bullpen sucks that's gonna come back and
bite him in the ass and Chris Sale is
our guy and you know as much as I love
David Price you know he had a really
rough outing against the Yankees in New
York and him cursing out Dennis
Eckersley I don't know I don't know that
that guy was like oh that's a Hall of
Famer man you don't curse out a [ __ ]
Hall of Famer so I'm worried that that
guy is a little you know what do you a
little shaky between the the years
they're a little old l Beckham they're
right you know I don't know I hope he is
it cuz if he isn't we got to beast he is
a beast but I'm just worried that when
he went down in New York and all of us
kind of imploded rather than being like
I'm gonna ruin that fat man titted
singing [ __ ] jackass Yankee fan they
still do that roll call thing it's like
Jesus Christ I always feel like a
musicals gonna break out after that yeah
they're you know what a lot of that and
then they do the YMCA thing I mean it's
you know and every time you think that's
the worst thing then we sing Sweet
Caroline it's just I don't know what has
happened to both of those franchises
it's so weird how so much [ __ ] just got
nicer but people are so much meaner in a
way you know like you go to New York see
like [ __ ] Yankees down went to a game
in 1983 there the whole family went down
there and it was I taking you [ __ ]
Louie into a day game and as you got to
New York there was literally cars just
burned out on the side of the [ __ ]
highway and I don't mean in the middle
of nowhere on some side road on the side
of the highway like burn to the [ __ ]
ground I remember that was one of the
things when Giuliani got in office it
was one of the first things he did was
he got those things off of the highway
that was such a bad [ __ ] look for New
York or maybe it was a good look cause
it was warning terror about terrorists
tourists about what they were about to
experience but uh I don't everybody was
gets Giuliani credit who was the head
the chief of police there that he fired
along the way so he'd get all the credit
well built you always have to be a [ __ ]
yeah I do
Giuliani
he's chief of police fired let's see
this guy's come on come on slow Internet
he's bilberry he has the slowest
internet in Los Angeles still [ __ ]
going and not me I don't you know I
don't even know like a sporting event
they used to always be like an olive
meadow they keep your head on a [ __ ]
swivel and Jesus Christ you have no idea
what you're gonna see that people acted
like [ __ ] animals
it was fights in the stands and all that
type of [ __ ] I'm not saying obviously
that I wanted to go back to that but
somewhere along the line like it just
became like it's like it's just weird
it's like you go into a Chucky Cheese
it's still loading by the way still
loading that's probably cuz i typed in
Giuliani and something negative that's
that's my guess I'm gonna go with the
old conspiracy theory here yeah anyways
I don't know you go to sporting events
now it's like every time there's a
stoppage of play then something happens
up on the [ __ ] flatscreen everybody
just stares at it with their mouths
hanging open and I really think that
that's like this thing so people like
don't fight and behave themselves you
know you know you get that camera on
your flat-screen TV and all those
[ __ ] nerds at the Best Buy sit there
watching you jerking off to the [ __ ]
Charlie's Angels on me-tv whatever
you're doing right but you know in
between those times when they're waiting
for you to [ __ ] your wife or whatever
those [ __ ] nerd perverts are doing
down there that for some reason is not
[ __ ] enforced you don't I mean you
got all this [ __ ] me to [ __ ]
happening and meanwhile these [ __ ]
nerds are watching you in your living
room
Babbitt's I'm not making this [ __ ] up
like they've gotten busted doing it I
don't know why they admitted to it they
like are you doing into like you know
we're not gonna say we're not
anyways yeah they just sit there [ __ ]
I mean if you're gonna if you're gonna
go after the the pervert
okay Giuliani renews ties with police
chief he out stood in 1995 William J
Bratton left in New York City pull New
York City Police Commissioner with mayor
Rudolph Giuliani the two men yeah that's
the guy from what I've heard I granted
this might have been people that hated
Giuliani which God knows a lot of people
do this might be [ __ ] but I don't
know what was it's coming from this is
the New York Times all right so they
hate Giuliani all right
the two men Rudolph Giuliani and his
former Police Commissioner William J
Bratton had not spoken to each other in
10 years this is from 10 years ago this
was written when they had crossed paths
a social gathering exchanged little more
than icy nods but time tragedy and
presidential campaign has started to
change all that I don't know what the
[ __ ] is I think that was the guy that
really turned it around that started on
the road where it's now like it's weird
it's like a my father-in-law 7 came down
who's standing at Brooklyn goes Geo this
is like it's like a theme park you know
it's like people ride bicycles along the
river and all this types it's sort of
like a it's sort of like if you have
money it's become this utopia there's
something I don't know
when does the pendulum swing back that's
what I want to know Jesus Christ because
I imagine in the 70s when New York
almost went bankrupt there was a bunch
of old people all was a dreamland
what was that grandma back when whites
were only allowed to play baseball back
when hit well I suppose those things
weren't right but uh you could leave
your door
unlocked that is the thing that anytime
you say good old days there's always
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] going on right I
don't
yeah bill yeah that really wasn't
anything deep I didn't say all right so
what I've been doing lately besides not
boozing tell you right now old [ __ ]
old freckles here I haven't drank all
this month it's been great man it's
really been great I'm still [ __ ]
tired though I having a kid you still
tired but uh I'm but like I remember one
day waking up when I was on the road
anticipating a hangover and not having
one and I was like wow it's pretty
awesome you know I'm trying to eat
wealth thinking of talking to a
nutritionist you know I'm saying I got
to get the answers to the test here
rather than listening to [ __ ] every
Tom Dick and Harry you know Dean Del Ray
knows what the [ __ ] he's talking about
but I'm getting bored with the diet I
got to add other [ __ ] and want to add
some vegan meals you know you know not
cuz I want to go vegan just because I
know if you eat them then you know your
stomach is flatter just give my body a
break from you know beef bourguignon
skirt steaks and all of that [ __ ] you
know I saw this thing the other dance
like you just you don't even know who to
[ __ ] to believe like one of the things
you know when you look at vegetarians
and you look at vegan people uh you know
there's an astounding level of fleshy
fat people that don't eat meat you know
what I mean and they'll eat french fries
because it's made from potatoes and
they're vegetarian but it's fried and
they'll say you know potatoes aren't
good for you anyways that far as I know
I'm a I shouldn't even say that I don't
to be all Oprah here and get people to
stop eating potatoes and then the whole
[ __ ] potato farm farming industry
Sue's me here at the Monday morning
podcast but there's just a lot you know
they like [ __ ] just all carbohydrates
and [ __ ]
and they just stay away from me I think
a lot of people love animals but they
hate reading is what I've sort of
learned from looking at vegetarians and
vegans people you know so they don't eat
meat but then they don't really know
what the [ __ ] it is they're doing but
the people that do take the time to do
it right
like nobody who lived in this house for
a hundred [ __ ] years evidently took
the time to do something right [ __ ] it
in a permit [ __ ] somebody licensed
[ __ ] all of that what did they do they
just [ __ ] lived here they had a
problem they asked a friend and I think
a lot of vegans and vegetarians do that
they [ __ ] talk to people rather than
reading and that's what I do because
it's easier it's easier than sitting
down and actually doing the [ __ ] work
so you know I see that you know like can
anybody if gundy your [ __ ] head can
anybody tell you whether having an egg
is good for you a bad at this point eggs
have been good bad good and now they're
starting to be bad again while people
who are saying they're good or [ __ ]
you know that Duke and it's like the
rubber match the rubber game whatever
the [ __ ] it's called right so I'm gonna
I'm gonna talk to a nutritionist and I'm
gonna you know try to read up on it but
it's it's really dry and if you actually
look up [ __ ] on becoming a vegetarian or
eating a little like that
like a vegan or something I mean it's
just Hatfields and McCoy and I'm McCoys
between the [ __ ] meat eaters the
carnivores and the vegetarian people and
there's a lot of money at stake no pun
intended and sorry about that so I I
think like the big farming cattle
[ __ ] people you know they're trying
to have all this [ __ ] come up first and
then all the tree-hugging like hey me
and like you know trees are alive man
those [ __ ] people are trying to say
that you know eating meat is is like
like I saw this thing right what they
were saying that this guy was trying to
say that like animals get protein from
eating plants and when you eat an animal
it's an indirect protein because you
should just gone directly to the plant
and it's like both then explained Tigers
and they're [ __ ] you know mr.
universe physiques as far as I know
which is I don't know [ __ ] so I should
shut up right now in Google what what at
Tigers eat what do Tigers eat meat only
no they're always in a bad mood I can't
even take a [ __ ]
Siberian the species diet ordinary
consists about 50% wild boar meat
doesn't that sound delicious if they
cannot get their paws on some wild boar
they've been known to eat elk deer in
legs I didn't do nothing and sometimes
even bears oh my god what sighs Jesus
Christ that's a big thing in Asia huh
putting like a bear and a tiger in a
[ __ ] cage and just filming it if
large sources of meat are not readily
available Siberian tigers will eat
rabbits fish and any rodents they can
get to let's see okay well there's no
meat in that suit and that's the first
thing I saw do Tigers eat plants what
the Tigers eat Siberian the species diet
consists that still this Tigers diet
eating Tigers eat a variety of prey
ranging in size from termites to
elephant calves all that would break my
heart to see a baby elephant get killed
however an integral component of the
diet law our large body prey weighing 45
pounds or larger such as moose d what
didn't [ __ ] mean moose and bear where
the [ __ ] are those things I thought they
were that moose were only over here deer
species pigs cows horses buffaloes and
goats yeah well they have a different
digestive system of evidently because if
you just [ __ ] ate that that's bait
they're basically on the Atkins diet
right yeah he's much [ __ ] banking as
you want Tigers looking at you like yeah
I realized that I realized that so
anyways I'm gonna try to [ __ ] I don't
know I'm gonna talk to a nutritionist
somebody read all the [ __ ] that I'm
supposed to read and maybe try to get
them to tell me some pill and you're
really gonna buy books on nutrition like
you're gonna [ __ ] read them anyways I
should probably read some advertising I
don't feel like [ __ ] doing that hey
I'm almost like halfway through this
season six of 77 Sunset Strip and
evidently as I said season six you gotta
watch it it's on a 4:00 a.m. on me TV
just take the [ __ ] thing I'm gonna
get more people to watch it because I'm
worried because I found out that they
started broadcasting all the episodes
back in November and I missed the first
five seasons and we're getting towards
the end here of season six because they
didn't do a full season they got
cancelled like three quarters of the way
through and I'd like to see the original
ones because I'd like to see what LA
looked back then you know hopefully they
do some exteriors although I know most
of it was formed on the back lot filmed
on the back lot and Warner Brothers but
[Music]
I'm loving this season so I'm worried
that the other one's gonna be a little
hokey cuz I guess a lot of people didn't
like season six first of all they fired
the whole [ __ ] cast they butchered
but I also didn't realize that they made
Efrem Zimbalist jr. z' character a lot
more surly and
but I'm loving them so now I'm worried
that I saw season six first and if I go
back and look at the others I'm not
gonna like the show the same with the
other people because I get you just get
used to how the guy behaves you know but
some of the lines man some of the [ __ ]
that people say on there here's
something like you know women are
talking about how guys behave around
them you know like and some of the [ __ ]
that they say it's like Jesus Christ I
mean I'm sure that guys out there but
what the [ __ ] you know son season 6 of
77 Sunset Strip they sounds like what
some of these women are describing
here's some of the [ __ ] I heard them say
guys saying to women on that show
pipe down shut up not to mention effort
Ephraim tries to bang his [ __ ]
secretary tried to look up her dress
went up so I'm just sitting ago this guy
would get me too so [ __ ] fast they'd
have his full head of hair spinning
right and then my favorite one ever
favored whenever as I mentioned on
another podcast is when he sat down in
this episode with the actor that ended
up playing the professor
Lloyd Gilligan's Island sorry I'm
talking through yawns right now but the
actor that played the professor in
Gilligan's Island and the guy was three
drinks in in ephram's meeting him it's
the middle of the day and the guy orders
his fourth drink and afro goes he got a
pretty active elbow for lunchtime you on
the sauce that is the one thing also
that I love about that show it makes you
feel better about drinking and smoking
because that from Zimbalist almost made
90 and there's barely a scene he's not
smoking a cigarette and he's really
smoking it too and that's just on the
take that they use so who knows all
right with that
should I read a little bit of
advertising yeah why don't I do that 77
Sunset Strip
oh jesus here we go there's somebody new
mint mobile mobile I'm going boo the big
and big wireless stands for a lot of
things big contracts big bills and big
fees like AT&T s new eight hundred
million dollar administration fee
increase Wow
they're just making up fees now I know I
love when they do that because they
think that you don't have a choice
what big Wireless doesn't want you to
know that there's a what is that there's
a way out to cut your wireless bill down
to just 15 bucks a month introducing
mint mobile the game-changing company
that's taking everything wrong with big
wireless and making it right well let's
hope they stay that way let's hope they
don't put the other guys out of the
business and then they become the devil
because that's usually what happens but
right now mid mobile mobile boom is are
the good guys mid mobile makes it so
easy to cut your wireless bill down to
just 15 bucks a month the [ __ ] it will
you'll have one text how can you do that
use your own phone with any mint mobile
plan you can keep your old number along
with all your existing contacts choose
between 2 5 or 10 GBS is that gigabytes
or 4G LTE plans no more paying for
unlimited data that you'll never use
every plan comes with unlimited talk and
text
well answers so you can safely annoy
your friends and loved ones and if
you're not 100% satisfied satisfied mint
mobile has you covered with their 7 day
money-back guarantee outfox your old
wireless bill and start saving with mint
mobile keep moving call to action to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month plus free shipping on your mint
Mobile SIM card go to MIT mobile comm /
/ that's mint mobile comm / berg cut
your wireless bill that fifteen bucks a
month and get free shipping on your mint
Mobile SIM card at mint mobile comm mi
NT mo bi le com
BRR somebody please try that out and let
me know how their services because
that's a hell of a [ __ ] price and I
can tell you I'm with Verizon and these
[ __ ] [ __ ] my bill always ends up
going up to like 300 bucks for no reason
and then I'm like why is it three in a
buck so that's weird at shooting a ham
like that let's do this don't wish this
will [ __ ] do that now it's only 180
no but then it [ __ ] goes back up
again I pay so much money for [ __ ]
cell phone
and [ __ ] DIRECTV you know somebody
was telling me if you just call up
DirecTV or something you just tell them
you're gonna [ __ ] get rid of it
they'll they all right it's not 150
bucks it's 45 because I think they're
just losing it with the cord cutters
Hotel tonight
ho Jesus three simple that [ __ ]
saxophone music from the 1950s every
time a woman came on the screen hotel
tonight is the go-to app for booking
great deals at great hotels
unlike other hotel booking sites Hotel
tonight doesn't have long endless lists
of a zillion hotel choices instead hotel
tonight shows you only the best deals at
the best hotels bedbug free they partner
with top-rated hotels to help them fill
their unsold rooms which is how you get
such great deals and even though the
name is hotel tonight
it's not just for tonight you can book
tonight tomorrow or beyond it's the
perfect it's perfect for planners as
well as procrastinators you can book
spontaneous weekend's three-day get away
staycation road trips business trip you
can book a hotel just so you can use the
[ __ ] pool download the hotel app
today to get great deals at the hotel
you actually want to stay in and with
the promo code birbee you are are you
can get $25 off your first eligible
booking hotel tonight
promo code burr get some cool
advertising here now huh cheap [ __ ]
cell service hotel tonight you know you
want to look your best when you're
enjoying both of those advantages right
well I got the thing for you Dollar
Shave club's this is plural Dollar Shave
Club delivers everything you need to
look feel and smell your best Dollar
Shave Club has everything you need to
get ready in the bathroom any particular
product that you have fallen in love
with outside of the razor and why oh I
guess that's for me I just love the idea
of the one way cherry I've never gotten
any how about some free samples you
bastards Dollar Shave Club yes that
Dollar Shave Club delivers everything
you need to look feel and smell your
best you name it shampoo check
conditioner got it body wash shut your
mouth toothpaste hair jugs
gel even a white that will leave your
tush feeling tingly clean evidently I'm
a big fan of their amber and lavender
calming body cleanser I would love to
try that second my wife goes honey
just wipe it on top of my head coming
dear
never smelled anything like it for just
five bucks you can get their daily
essential status set it comes with body
cleanser one wipe charese
they're amazing but wipes their
world-famous shave butter and their best
razor the six blade executive keep the
blades coming for a few bucks a month
and add in shampoo toothpaste or
anything else you need for the bathroom
check it all out at dollarshaveclub.com
/ / that's dollarshaveclub.com / /
alright and lastly but not leastly
I'm not trying to cause any advertiser
or enemies here hit stamps calm
everybody mm-hmm
the US Postal Service is an important
tool for any business stamps.com is the
easiest way to access all the amazing
services of the post office stamps calm
never closes right like that
the street did print postage for letters
or packages at your convenience
24/7 print postage for any class of mail
right from your own computer the exact
amount of postage every time never run
to pay or overpay again stamps.com saves
you time and money which you can use to
grow your business by and print official
US postage for any any package any class
of mail using your own computer and
they'll send you a digital scale
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps comm will even help you decide
the best class of mail based on your
needs no need to leased an expensive
postage meter and there are no long term
commitments I use stamps comm to send
out all of my posters speaking of which
my limited edition that you can only get
at my shows which I did not have in
Minneapolis and Detroit unfortunately
because the ones I got were the leftover
ones from Dublin and by the time they
got here they were all [ __ ] up but I'm
gonna have them in Houston in Dallas and
I use stamps calm to send them out I'm a
[ __ ] if I can figure out how to use
their scale and get some postage so can
you and right now you too can enjoy the
stamps.com service with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale got the
hiccups go to stamps come click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in birth that stamps comm enter
Barbie you are hey by the way you know
what I got a I got an email from Darrin
King credible drummer one of the best
drummers I've ever seen to be honest
with you and I had no idea that he could
sing and play guitar but he did a cover
of Ritchie
I got him saber is it Richie Havens they
make sure I have this right [ __ ] yeah
yes I was correct Richie Havens does a
song called freedom and he did a cover
version of that that then goes into
something else that is [ __ ]
incredible I tweeted out the video and
will have a link to it on the mm podcast
Jesus Christ you know I like watching
how talented that guy is I don't even
know what the [ __ ] I'm even
doing in this business man incredible
incredible monster talent check it out
and I heard he has a solo album coming
out people were alluding to it I hope he
does if he does we're gonna promote it
here and I hope you guys buy it because
he is the real deal all right let's
check out some am I gonna read some
stories I know you know what I'm
actually gonna do I actually came across
this [ __ ] good thing it says news is bad
for you okay this is from something the
Guardian calm says news is bad for you
and giving up reading it will make you
happier all right now I'll tell you
right now I didn't need this [ __ ]
article to tell me this I just realized
it I figured it out after I went down a
rabbit hole of [ __ ] you know
conspiracy theory you guys remember that
people listen to the podcast 10 years
ago I mean I was [ __ ] I was you know
I was mystic you know chemtrail guy you
know I was that guy saying you got to
shut down the Federal Reserve and I had
no solution to do like what would what
you would do after that you know I'm
sure people that are well read on it had
the solution but I didn't so I was just
walking around freaking people out I was
a [ __ ]
basically so anyways it says news is bad
for your house so I just stopped
watching the [ __ ] all right I'm just
banking on the fact that there's gonna
be some smart people with a good heart
that that they're gonna lead us out of
this [ __ ] mess cuz I don't have any
solutions alright I go on stage I jump
around like a monkey and I make you
laugh okay that's my lane and as the
rock used to say know your role and shut
your mouth
so I'm staying over there I try to watch
the news I I try I can't you know it's
the weirdest thing going from Obama to
trump go from Obama where all they did
was lick his balls for eight years and
then they go to trump and and it's just
like all they do is [ __ ] on the guy the
entire [ __ ] time and they're both
kind of doing you know with the foreign
policy the same [ __ ] [ __ ] although I
don't Trump is like a [ __ ] lunatic
you don't mean I know I heard I wasn't
the Howard Stern Show and he went on
this [ __ ] rant about Russia
it was just not talking about the
[ __ ] people just talking about you
know of ladi Dadi over there because I'm
sick of people [ __ ] talking about
Russia you know like like they're not
that bad he's like they [ __ ] you know
they killed gay people they kill
reporters just for having a difference
of opinion and he's right he's [ __ ]
right I don't know I I once that his his
his [ __ ] wife wore that coat when he
was gonna go visit those kids that she
was gonna go visit those kids that
they'd stuck in cages and she wore a
jacket that said I don't really care do
you and they tried oh that had to do
with fake news it's just like it's
literally like listening to a toddler to
lie and I god bless you if you can still
watch that and try and stay politically
active because I don't know it's it's
just too [ __ ] depressing I can't
[ __ ] deal with it so I choose not to
watch and the last presidency you know I
just I just it was I couldn't [ __ ]
you know I had hope and then I was just
like oh well this is gonna be more of
the same oh bankers don't go to jail oh
yeah yeah insurance companies could do
whatever their whatever they [ __ ]
want and yeah we're not going to
constructively criticize our foreign
policy we're just gonna stay the [ __ ]
course and shut down the government
every [ __ ] August for a week and our
solution is always gonna be to say well
what if we raise the debt right you know
and then meanwhile everything that his
wife did was just considered like
angelic it's just it was the whole
[ __ ] thing was annoying that was like
when he was in office was like watching
a [ __ ] award show everybody's just
walking around blowing each other
talking about how [ __ ] brilliant they
are and then this probably went from
what an awards show to a [ __ ] train
wreck I honestly don't know how people
have this stomach to pay attention like
you're you're a whole other level tough
mentally that I am so anyways his his
[ __ ] article here says news is bad
for you and giving up reading it will
make you happier alright in the past few
decades the fortune fortunate among us
have recognized the hazards of living
with an overabundance of food
parentheses obesity and diabetes and
having started to change and have
started to change our diets but most of
us do not yet understand that news is to
the mind what sugar is to the body news
is easy to digest the media feeds as
small bites of trivial matter tidbits
that don't really concern our lives and
don't require thinking that's why we
experience almost no saturation unlike
reading a book or long magazine articles
which require thinking we can swallow
limitless quantities of news flashes
which are bright colored candies for the
mind today we have reached the same
point in relation to the to information
that we face twenty years ago in regard
to food we're beginning to recognize how
toxic news can be and I agree with all
of this but everybody can't stop paying
attention or else you know somebody has
to pay attention right somebody's got to
be like you just can't put it on cruise
control so I know if I hundred percent
agree with this I just know I'm not
gonna be the Gandhi that leads us out of
this you know so as long as I know that
I mean I will abuse can be content to
listen to Howard in the morning and then
I listen to [ __ ] baseball at night
that's what I do and don't pretend to
know things all right news misleads all
might take the following event a car
drives over a bridge in the bridge
collapses what is what is the news media
focus on the car the person in the car
where he came from where he planned to
go how he was he transitioning how they
didn't say that how he experienced the
crash parentheses if he survived but
that is all irrelevant what's relevant
the structural stability of the bridge
that's the underlying risk that has been
lurking and could lurk in other bridges
well they get to that after they go
painstakingly through the horror of the
end of that man's life or life-altering
injuries and then they get to his family
and they're all crying and all of that
[ __ ] you know as much as a [ __ ] as I am
I always turn that [ __ ] off
you know like out here we had a hostage
situation at a Trader Joe's and the
people I was with were just watching it
and watching and watching it's like like
just out of curiosity what are you gonna
do if this guy just runs out and such
shooting people in the [ __ ] head like
you want to watch this these people in
the store are [ __ ] terrified this is
the worst [ __ ] moment of their life
alright the news eventually is going to
tell you what happened and they're gonna
give you an edited version so you not to
see people's brains getting blown out
you know and why you know they literally
had like the employees were crying and a
lot [ __ ] and then I found on the end you
know some poor woman died was it was
it's [ __ ] terrible it one I'm just
gonna sit at home watching it for hours
ordering food you know going online are
they tweeting from there or what's going
on then all these [ __ ] [ __ ] on
YouTube at YouTube on Twitter or these
social media if you're gonna go on and
say the obvious oh my god so sad I'm
like freaking out right now I love that
oh is that what you're doing are you
freaking out of the safety your own home
why don't you make this about yourself
your [ __ ] Jesus social media but is
people is a lot of [ __ ] that says that's
depressing too but you know what
podcasts actually feed the soul I
believe I'm part of the problem news
misleads Bill Byrne misleads anyways
plowing ahead we are not rational enough
to be exposed to the press see this guy
saying we're all dumb watching an
airplane crash on television is going to
change your attitude toward that risk
regardless of its real probability if
you think you can compensate with the
strength of your own inner contemplation
you are wrong
I think the subtext of this is you're
dumb [ __ ] bankers and economists who
have powerful incentives to compensate
for news borne hazards have shown that
they cannot the only solution cut
yourself off from the news consumption
entirely News is irrelevant out of the
approximately 10,000 news stories you
have read in the last 12
it's name one that because you consumed
it allowed you to make a better decision
about the serious matter affecting your
life your career your business well I
would say anything about the environment
you know Jesus guys guys chip off the
old block yes paint with a broad brush
the point is the consumption of news is
irrelevant to you but people find it
very difficult to recognize what's
relevant it's much easier to recognize
what's new alright I think we get the
point here news has no explanatory power
news items are bubbles popping on the
surface of a deeper world ooh that's
deep that's not like a [ __ ]
progressive rock band like a line in the
song in 74 I imagine will accumulate
facts that help you understand the world
sadly no the relationship is inverted
the important stories are non stories
yeah I would agree with that
slow powerful movement that developed
below journalist radar but have a
transforming effect the more news
factoids you digest the less of the big
picture you will understand well maybe
that's why everybody's yelling each
other news is toxic to your body this
I'll just read the headlines here news
increases cognitive errors news and hip
it's thinking news works like a drug
news waste time news makes us passive
well that worked with me news kills
creativity
well there you go Jesus Christ that's
pretty [ __ ] negative huh let's get to
some positive [ __ ] I got I got a [ __ ]
note from a possible visit to Dublin Vic
Bravo Rove Nick Dubrovnik Croatia my
friend while you're checking where the
hell I'm contacting you from let me jump
you with invitation invitation to my
country slash City I run brewery and we
are in debt at the moment so don't
expect this is money interesting
invitation this is opportunity for you
to check out crazy side of Buckland's
and getting hours and hours of future
material by the way you're funny well
thank you sir that read like a [ __ ]
ransom note from Eastern Europe and I
would be lying to you if I wasn't a
little
afraid to go to your bar I need a couple
of those in there you know while you're
checking where all you got the hell I'm
contacting you from let me jump in with
an invitation let me jump in with
invitation you you [ __ ] talk like
Ivan Drago listen buddy I'm gonna try to
get as close to dumb broth Nick as I
possibly can
I wish your bar was making more money
and I'd love to go in there and help you
out with your [ __ ] monthly rent buy
booze in my face off but I don't I could
tell you I don't think I'm gonna make it
there Eastern European tour Jesus Christ
if this is all I'm getting this is all
least Eastern Europe where Eastern
European tour dear Billy bald burger oh
come on now I was feeling I was feeling
good about myself I'm a huge fan of good
comedy and f is for family is my
favorite thing on next flicks well thank
you very much therefore I am very
excited that you were thinking of
visiting Prague Czech Republic comedy
scene in Prague is pretty much
non-existence oh really so I'm sure you
would kill with your knock-knock jokes
if you are interested pint of beer costs
between one to two dollars and it's
delicious he also have to try
traditional alcohol drink sleeve Ovie's
it's made from distilled plums and has
about 51 percent of alcohol okay I'm in
you could visit the Czech Hockey Hall of
Fame or you could go to see Jaromir Jagr
play some second division hockey oh that
would be cool [ __ ] I thought probably
only gonna be there for a night I think
this is going to be a bunch of
one-nighters here a while back you
mentioned you saw the movie anthropoid
about a checklist Avakian paratroopers
assassinating high-ranking German Nazi
official I love that movie
the movie ends with the final shootout
in the church you can actually go to the
crypts of the church and see the bullet
holes from the Indesit incident I'm
[ __ ] doing that I hope you decide to
come and share your murican wisdom with
us savages thanks and go make love to
your lovely wife oh thank you god bless
you go [ __ ] your wife you [ __ ]
redheaded prick
stern European toy hey Bill I just
wanted to say that I know a lot of
people waiting for you to come to Poland
oh great I guess your agents already
figured out that Warsaw seems the most
logical place to do your show as it's
the biggest city in the capital it's
located somewhat in the middle of the
country so most of people from outside
Warsaw like me will be able to come and
see you live I'm 100% sure you'll sell
out all the tickets plus Warsaw is a
great place to visit because of its
history and of course all the cool stuff
going on there
I guess people from the States think
you'll see white bears and trams and
horse-drawn carts on the street but
that's not the case
I didn't think that I just thought I'd
see four people trying to screw in a
lightbulb ah sorry just like everywhere
else
we've got hipsters and Starbucks
moderately fat lazy [ __ ] and shopping
malls and generally people wasting their
lives on social media yeah yeah that's
that's a reoccurring thing anyway my
friends and I can't wait for your show
thanks and go [ __ ] yourself yeah
everybody's staring at their phones is a
big thing and I do that all the time
persistent cold you may have walking
pneumonia go see a doctor when you get
back to LA I need a doctor
soft tires and Nazi symbolism I love
this guy this guy's just he's just doing
the whole gamut isn't he running the
gamut hey let's look that up let's see
what the [ __ ] that means how did that
expression come about all right run the
gamut origin meaning the entire range
the word gamut traces its origins to the
Middle Ages and a system for designating
musical notes around the turn of the
second millennium the [ __ ] you mean the
second millennium I thought this was the
second millennium mm right is it a
millennium a thousand years I'm an evil
monk developed a system Jesus bill hey
you know just get to the point like I
try to be informed like
the second you're gonna bring up a
[ __ ] monk around the turn of the
second millennium Guido of our Aras Oh a
medieval monk developed a system of
solemnization ie designating musical
notes by syllable names while today we
are familiar with the sung syllables
doremi paws Oh Lottie back in Guido's
time he died in 1050 they had a
hexitonic scale six note and he used to
symbol three me fossil and LA and the it
represented the lowest note or three be
facile heed la and okay okay
that's why play drums and tell jokes UT
what represents the lowest tone
recognized in music theory at that time
the second G below middle C what the
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] about Wayne so
what is the gamut the range of notes
okay building on this denotation
detonation I don't know damn it
eventually came to mean the whole
musical scale oh so you're running the
whole [ __ ] scale okay Jesus Christ
all right hey building soft tires and
Nazi symbolism by the way hey Bill I
think I can answer both of your
questions from Thursday's podcast I'm in
law school in a motorsport fanatic so
the questions these questions are right
in my wheelhouse all right what if
you're in law school let's say you know
about Nazi symbolism do you prosecute
hate crimes I hope number one why the
soft tires and MotoGP principally you're
right I know the tires degrade towards
the end of the race so it makes sense to
use harder ones to get consistent
performance especially now that slightly
sliding the bike is the quickest way
around the track how the [ __ ] you learn
how to do that is crazy I mean I've seen
people do that in cars you know drifting
but you know you're on four wheels like
the level of balance and scale the
ability become one with
the machines don't work a lot in Germany
Lorenzo used a soft front tire while
Marquez took the hard one for the rears
Lorenzo was on a medium tire and Marquez
on the soft Marquez is a special driver
and tends to get a better feeling for
the bike with a hard tire the sidewalls
simply don't wobble around too much
Lorenzo's bet was to use the superior
pace of the soft tire more grip to build
enough of an advantage to win this is
fascinating Marquez meanwhile expected a
tight field and wanted to nurse his
tires while keeping with the pack thus
having enough tire left for the last lap
and a final attack for a win which is
exactly what he did
simply put the drivers have to decide
between an early pace advantage and
therefore superior track position with
soft tires and the consistency of the
hearts ad ad changing conditions
different writing styles and bikes to
that and you'll see how hard it is to
pick up a winning package well my thing
is is there a way for him to know what
Marc Marquez is going to be running
considering he's the best rider out
there as far as I can tell no disrespect
to Jorge Lorenzo I know he's wanted a
couple of times but the championship I
believe he's won two of them no matter
what tire you're gonna have you're not
going to open up this like
insurmountable lead so I just think
eventually that soft tire is gonna
[ __ ] wear out and then Marquez is
behind he's gonna overtake you and then
then he can ride hard for the first time
in the race he'd beat the [ __ ] out of
those tires but by the time they get
[ __ ] up it the race is gonna be over
before that happens I don't know but
thanks for that that is that is fastened
because everybody's you watch racing
geez bunch people driving around driving
around the track driving around a circle
stock car racing why do you need to know
go turn left yeah that's all you need to
know band Nazi symbolism I'm enrolled in
one of the best school I love how people
are too dumb to understand racing and
then they sit there and they [ __ ] on it
I'm enrolled in one of the best law
schools in Germany over here
displaying Nazi symbolism is punishable
with up to five years in prison in the
context of the whole legal system it's
quite an unusual article of the law
usually this is amazing so because
because you're a lawyer in Germany
usually the political background of an
opinion is irrelevant to the criminal
repercussions to avoid discrimination
usually objective factors are used
instead of political ones it was
discussed whether banning and punishing
Nazi sympathetic displays is
constitutional it is an infringement on
the freedom of speech yes it is and also
lets you know who the Nazis yeah the one
argument that won in court was this was
the historic significance in Germany the
Constitution with by the way I'm loving
all these these letters from around the
world this is [ __ ] incredible if I
could just get some women to write it I
know I'm off porting ladies but you know
that kind of gives you an opportunity to
put me in my place which is one of my
favorite things here with my wife so and
here she shits all over me I love it
giggling like a schoolgirl the
Constitution was put into place in 1949
while most cities still look like
downtown Baghdad circa 2004 and when the
ovens of house which had just cooled
down Jesus the content of the
Constitution is an answer to all the
[ __ ] that went down between 1933 and
1945 yeah because most of those lunatics
died or were put to death and then some
more rational people like hey let's try
to prevent that happen and again I look
at the city yeah this is amazing you can
see all the way to the other city
because there's no cities left anyways
so the Constitution is the answer to
that's really a no you don't see a lot
about Germany other than 1933 to 1945 or
the show [ __ ] about you know World War
one but they don't show about the steps
that they took afterwards to ensure that
this wasn't going to happen again I'm
sure there's a nice book on it that I
could sit down and read if I wasn't such
a [ __ ] and he was denying support of
that regime
is part of the constitutions inherent
character I agree with that the problem
it doesn't change anything in symbolism
we can now point at our laws and tell
other countries see we learned and what
do the neo-nazis do they use [ __ ]
code which is not forbidden such as 88 I
guess that means Heil Hitler
or hkn krz shirts which in German is
recognized is saying Hawking Kreutz
which equals swastika I swear to God
those [ __ ] parody the Run DMC logo
with H K n space k RZ shirts I had no
idea
Wow thanks for the podcast they keep me
laughing during exams looking forward to
your German European tour you freckle
[ __ ]
you know that's got to be the most
fascinating [ __ ] I've heard about
Germany since you know the same [ __ ]
that they show a zillion times on on the
History Channel me obviously got to show
that so you know hopefully that never
happens again
but they should probably shine a light
on this to know that that is going down
I don't know it's hard man I really
looked like the Nazis dick to kind of
like a [ __ ] I think I used to a bit
on this they're kind of like a band that
had a bunch of hits like [ __ ] 40
years ago and now they're coming back
and it's just you know there's no
original members they don't have the
magic anyway it's over it's over it's
it's a you know it's like a uh you know
some some bands it's just their name
becomes toxic after a while you know
although sometimes they're so bad that
they come back and people love him again
I don't know it's probably a bad analogy
but that's pretty frightening that that
shit's going down that people still like
you know I don't know
I've never really been to a Holocaust
Museum it says I just don't think I
could handle it you know knowing that
people are capable of that level of
[ __ ] evil just literally separating
you know it's [ __ ] in slavery the [ __ ]
at the board to separate parents from
their children to sit there and [ __ ]
do that I know I don't give anybody a
pass even the [ __ ] kid down there
like this is my job
quit your [ __ ] job I'm gonna [ __ ]
doing this like Wendy when is that kid
screaming crying voice gonna leave you a
[ __ ] head for the rest of your life
oh my god especially not having a kid
and knowing like how much they need like
my daughter just came in she was like
wine and all that for whatever reason
she wanted to hug me you know I don't
know why but they they need just to take
that away from a kid at just it's
[ __ ] you know over some I don't know
did this get you know there's got to be
another way right anyways you sent my
brother to the hospital the [ __ ] you
talking about can I legally read this
without getting alright hey Billy bro
killer my brother and I went to your
show early your Early Show in
Minneapolis a couple weeks ago and as we
were leaving he was complaining about
his back and shoulder hurting being the
douche I am I assumed he was whining
about the uncomfortable seats over the
next few days he started coughing and
hearing a rattle in his chest yeah okay
well go to the doctor he went to the doc
and as a record it turns out at some
point during you set his right lung made
like the Falcons in Super Bowl 51
collapsed well that's not from laughing
that was like you know you went there
yeah it's probably everything he did up
and to that point he spent I would love
to take credit for any joke being funny
enough to make somebody's lung collapse
but I think your uh thank you uh yeah
you're looking at the ass end of the
problem there buddy he spent the next
six days in the hospital and had to get
a tube stuck through his ribcage like
Carl Weathers desk the death scene in
predator
then they hooked that [ __ ] up
to a Dustbuster sucked out the air that
was outside of his lung and sewed the
hole shut that's fascinating he finally
got out of the hospital and is doing
fine but I just thought you'd appreciate
knowing you're at the level where your
comedy cause someone's organ to explode
like the goddamn Death Star keep this up
and you'll be well on your way to fixing
the overpopulation problem anyways can't
wait for you to get come back to
Minnesota so you can finish the job and
get us left lung hope all is well with
the family thanks glad you guys came out
and I'm glad your brother's doing
alright alright I think that's the I
think that's the podcast here for this
week all right I think there was a
Formula One race today I'm taping this
Sunday night I got to sit down and watch
that but I got so much [ __ ] to do is
that it is do I have anything oh yeah
this weekend I'm gonna be with Nate
Craig in Houston all right Houston Texas
in July as a bald redheaded male and
then I'm gonna be in Dallas I don't know
how many shows um [ __ ] do it yeah let
me check it out here alright so here's
the deal
Thursday I got a show at revention Music
Center in Texas Friday I have a show at
revention Music Center in Houston Texas
there's still tickets to Thursday Friday
sold out and then I got two shows in the
pavilion up in Dallas at the Toyota
Music Factory also I added a show right
before the rough and rowdy in Rochester
New York right outside of Buffalo which
I haven't been to in a zillion years
Rochester former home of the Rochester
Royals that then became the Cincinnati
Royals then the Kansas City / Omaha
kings then the Kansas City Kings and
then the Sacramento Kings hey Bill why
were they Kansas City in Omaha King
spoke as they used to split their home
games between both those cities seeing
which town gave a [ __ ] more K and the
city didn't have any college football
Omaha did well I guess it's Lincoln
Nebraska right where is the University
Nebraska I only went to a [ __ ] game
out there I always forget where that's
at
then they became the Sacramento Kings
I'm into that [ __ ] I'm into past
histories you wanna hear a couple of
cool ones all right here's a good one
kansas city scouts NHL team moved to
Colorado became the Colorado Rockies and
that moved to New Jersey became the New
Jersey Devils okay I can't do all your
homework for you but I can do some of it
all right the original Washington
Senators 1901 to 1960 they left and
became the Minnesota Twins and then the
Senators came back briefly in Washington
almost like they retained the name like
the Cleveland Browns
there was a second incarnation of the
[ __ ] Washington Senators and they
also failed and then they moved to Texas
and became the Texas Rangers all right
you want to hear some more what else do
I got all right the New York Yankees who
were they originally the Baltimore
Orioles 1901 to 1902 then they became
the New York Highlanders 1903 to 1912
then they became the New York Yankees
1913 to present now the Baltimore oiler
Orioles I knew they were the old st.
Louis Browns but I didn't realize they
were the first they were the Milwaukee
Brewers in 1901 then they were the st.
Louis Browns 1902 to 1953 and from 1954
till now they became the Orioles all
right that's it God I want to talk to
you guys anyone about this what the
Oakland A's is that is that what you
were asking about well they were the
Philadelphia Athletics from 1901 to 1954
then the Kansas City Athletics to 1955
in 1967 and then they would the became
the Oakland A's 1968 to 1986 and then
the Oakland Oakland Athletics 1987 to
present I don't know what that means as
far as I'm concerned they've been the
Oakland A's or the Athletics since 68
but that's what this [ __ ] thing said
to me you know you know I learned about
all
this [ __ ] a lot of teams have passed
through Kansas City started there I've
gone through there and then that they
just [ __ ] you know kansas city scouts
Kansas City Kings Kansas City Athletics
I've had a lot of people come and go you
know and there's only one solution that
I can think of there's a lot of [ __ ] in
Kansas City
all right go [ __ ] yourselves I'll talk
to you on Thursday